Narrator: While filming this scene
from Disney's "The Mandalorian,"
the actors could see their surroundings,
but the surroundings
weren't actually there.
All of this is just LED screens
displaying backgrounds pre-made
in a video game engine.
Compare that with this fight scene
from "Avengers: Endgame."
Where actors jumped
around in a sea of green,
imagining how VFX artists
would make this planet look
once filming had ended.
"The Mandalorian" is one of
the first major productions
to choose LED walls over green screens.
And the benefits for the actors
are just the tip of the iceberg.
LED walls make the lighting
better, filming smoother,
and in certain cases, cost a lot less
than using green screens.
But to understand why the
team behind "The Mandalorian"
chose these LED screens,
we have to understand just how they work.
"Mandalorian" showrunner Jon Favreau
revolutionized virtual
production while directing
"The Lion King" and "The Jungle Book."
However, the process for these two remakes
still relied heavily on blue screen
and post-production work.
For "The Mandalorian,"
LED wall technologies
seemed like the next logical step
given the show's production
budget and time frame.
Now, you may be thinking,
'This isn't so new, I've seen
something like this before.'
And you're right, kind of.
The predecessor to what we
see on "The Mandalorian"
is a driving scene like
this one, from "Dr. No."
You've got the actor in the car
and behind them, a screen with footage
of the road they've traveled.
But the technology was limited.
Say you want to move the camera angle
during the scene.
That projected footage can't
move with the camera.
But by using Unreal Engine,
tech borrowed from the video game field,
that problem is solved.
Artists can create a
photorealistic 3D background
that moves strictly with
the camera's field of view,
known as the frustum.
So if the camera swings
around and changes angles,
the background shifts in
precisely the same way.
This allows motion-tracked cameras
to execute traditional
cinematography techniques
within the virtual set,
achieving cinematic movements
like the parallax effect, where
an object in the foreground
moves at a different
speed than the background,
amplifies the illusion of filming
at an actual location.
Now that LED screens can
move with the camera's eye,
virtual sets can solve a bunch
of green screen problems.
The biggest one probably being lighting.
Richard Bluff: We've all
seen movies, TV shows,
where the lighting on the day
didn't necessarily match
the post-production work
that was added many, many months later.
Narrator: That's Richard Bluff,
Industrial Light and
Magic's VFX supervisor
for "The Mandalorian."
He says lighting is
one of the key benefits
of working with virtual sets.
The light coming from the LEDs
provide realistic colors and reflections
on the actors and props,
something you simply can't
achieve with green screen.
They are also able to completely
avoid the problem of spill.
To better understand that,
we talked to Kim Libreri at Epic Games,
creators of Unreal Engine,
which was used to build the virtual sets
for "The Mandalorian."
Kim Libreri: The problem
with the green screen
is that you have to have
a green screen behind you.
And what that does is
that instead of projecting
beautiful lighting for
what the environment
would be behind you,
it basically puts a lot
of green light on you.
And we call that "spill."
If you wrap an actor with
a big 360 LED wall,
you can light in a way
that you would never be able
to do on a green screen.
So you can really make it feel
like the characters are
embedded in their environments.
Narrator: This green screen spill
would've been an even
bigger problem than usual
for "The Mandalorian,"
whose main character
gets a shiny new suit of armor
early on in the season.
So realistic lighting from the LEDs
makes the show look better.
But virtual sets help with
practical concerns too.
Take this scene in the
office of The Client,
played by Werner Herzog.
In a scene like this,
surely they just built
a simple set, right?
Wrong.
All of this is that same LED screen.
According to Richard,
only the desk, the floor,
and one or two columns
were really there.
Richard: Everything else
was displayed on the screen.
But this allowed us to limit
the amount of stage space that we used
in shooting season one of "Mandalorian,"
which has, understandably, a
big impact on time and budget.
Narrator: To be fair,
the initial investment
in a virtual set like this is huge.
However, the creators
claim that money saved
from traveling to locations,
building new sets,
and costly post-production,
can make the investment worth it.
Along with saving time and money,
the team developed a system
that allowed artists to make changes
and control the world
on the day of shooting.
Settings like exposure, color,
animation playback, and fill lighting
are available to the filmmakers
at a moment's notice.
If they want to move a mountain
from one side of the virtual set
to the other, they can,
right there on set.
Not only is it helpful for the actor,
who no longer has to imagine
where that mountain is,
but it's a game changer for
the director of photography.
Richard: Because in the distance,
if there's a mountain range
that is a story point,
then the DP's no longer guessing
where those elements are,
he can frame up to them.
Narrator: The virtual set
constructed for season one
was 75 feet in diameter, 21 feet high,
and also had a roof composed of LEDs.
The cast and crew referred to
this space as "The Volume."
Richard: And we had doors
that can kinda close in
to almost give you full 360-
degree coverage of LED screens,
minus the floor.
It's driven by a small group of machines
running Unreal and our
StageCraft technologies.
Narrator: At the end of the
day, the big question is,
do virtual sets really mean
the end for green screens?
Well, even "The Mandalorian,"
with it's technological advances,
used a version of a green screen,
but via the LED wall.
Another capability of virtual sets
is to choose pinpointed areas of the wall
and turn those green.
Richard: Now, we now
have the ability to limit
the amount of green screen
that's visible behind the character.
So now it doesn't wrap
around the entire stage,
it's just a little piece, but also,
they gain the lighting
from that environment.
Which gives us a more seamless
result in post-production.
Narrator: Additionally,
scenes involving explosives
are best kept to traditional methods.
This is to prevent LEDs
from getting damaged.
So will green screens survive
this wave of tech innovation?
Richard: Eventually, of course, we hope
never to use green screen.
But, I still see that there will be
a future for it in the short-term,
because there's likely always
a need to remove people,
to add additional action behind them.
But we are getting to the point
where the amount of green
screen that's being used
is massively reduced
and the sky's the limit right now.